أوه ، trippin fic ، هذا
هو أول مدرس روبوت للعبة بينج بونج
في العالم صنعته شركة تدعى عمران
متخصص في الذكاء
الاصطناعي والروبوتات ، أعتقد أنني جيد جدًا في
لعبة تنس الطاولة جيدًا ، دعنا نراها مقابل رسوم
أعتقد أنني بحاجة إلى بعض المساعدة  حسنًا
[موسيقى
] ، فباستخدام مزيج من
نظام الكاميرا ثلاثي الأبعاد والروبوتات لتتبع
الكرة ، أعادت اللقطة وتحسين
لعبتي كلها في جزء من الثانية ، لكن
لا تتوقع مني أن ألعب ضد
الأتعاب الضعيفة في الطابق السفلي الخاص بك في أي وقت  قريبًا ،
هذا مجرد إثبات للمفهوم
للتباهي بتقنيات رون ، نفس
التكنولوجيا التي تجعل أربعة PS جيدة في لعبة
ping pong لها تطبيقات أخرى مثل
الضيافة في أتمتة المصانع
وسلامة السائق من أجل السلام ليست مثالية
تمكنت من الحصول على  لقطات زوجية ولكن
يقول Omron إنه يتعلم من
أخطائه باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي لتحسين
الطالب أصبح المعلم
[موسيقى]